[Applause]
hey there the spotlight is a bit
much but we'll we'll soldier on um
so
so here's the goal right so the goal is
um
i mean the session is called feature
engineering made simple i'm going to
assume that the the audience here you
know
i'm not going to go into what feature
engineering is because i
have to assume that that
everybody is very familiar with
what that means
so the goal is twofold right
so the sort of what we will do
explicitly
is
introduce hopefully
what you will find to be
at least what i find to be cool
innovations that make feature
engineering easier
and more systematic
the other thing sort of implicitly will
be doing is is as i walk through
as i walk through the session
what will become apparent is that
we are going through a fairly structured
process meaning
we do x then we do y then we do z and so
on and so forth so even though it
clearly won't be spelled out
hopefully this will end up being
a a
proceduralization of the future
engineering process as well right and
then at the end
i'll throw up this sort of magic block
diagram which will show the flow that i
went through and we have found that that
that that that
ends up being a
pretty good way to go about this in a
bunch of different cases right so um
so we'll start so this is what we'll do
and and the the the the mechanism is as
follows
so
so we'll take you through
an actual feature engineering exercise
using a um open source stack that we
have introduced called anovos
um
and and
i will do the voiceover where i the rest
of the team is kajan and you know
what i would have liked to have done is
hung out here because i tend to be
fidgety and kind of walk around but that
is not possible because then
they can't film and then you have a
in the video i guess you have a
disembodied voice which they wanted a
voice with a body so
so i'm going to be standing here but i'm
still going to be fidgeting you know i'm
i'm
i i have not been uh
a faculty member for a long time but the
whole
lecturing muscle memory is lecturing
muscle memory and you tend to walk
around which i can't do here
so i'm going to be doing the voice over
and and we have two others we have
kajanan who runs ai and
and machine learning at mobile walla
so a super smart guy you know his his
just just
stellar career he just made one mistake
in his life
which was to do his phd under my
guidance
and and he's still recovering from one
of my best phd students and then after
he graduated he went and
kind of ran machine learning at a large
telecom company called singapore telecom
and then then then a few years later we
hired him
so i begged him to come back and and he
does
machine learning at mobile walla and we
have akil akhil mamen who runs uh
who runs basically the feature
engineering product set at mobile right
so that's the team you guys have for
better or for worse
and uh and let's let's start so kajanan
will be
will be managing the the visuals and the
visual is you know
it's not really a
deck kind of presentation will show you
a few slides but it's primarily a
notebook right
and what i'm going to assume
i just did the same thing
at uh i don't know if any of you guys
were in machine learning ops world in
toronto last week we ran the tutorial
there
uh as well
and and um
what we found maybe that's not the case
here so so the idea is of course because
it's a workshop you are running you know
you have the the the
the library loaded
uh on your laptop or at least some of
you
and are kind of
working with us as we as we move along
you're running those commands some of
the commands take a little bit of time
so i'll alert basically saying that look
let's not do that but the the dockerized
thing that you should have downloaded
has the output already so you can
walk through or
you know if if if you are not if you are
just going to you know if you're just
going to take this as a lecture that's
fine as well
uh
uh you know so we're going to hang out
here for for the next couple of days uh
super happy to to to walk you through
this or show you stuff
uh at wherever they'll assign a table
for us outside right
so so so let's start
so um
again um
the backdrop of this the the workflow
will happen through this thing called
anovos
these are the various uh
various things that
and this is the only marketing slide
that you'll you know so our cmo has
promised to me i promised my cmo that
we'll show that so these are um these
are the the rel of engine of the repo
where you find the repo we have a slack
channel
uh you know uh there are a couple of
sort of very cool
companies that are started using this
pretty pretty pretty well
so if you are on slack you can see the
back and forth that goes on and and and
so we we also sponsor a
a group called feature engineers which
has grown you know all over the world so
that's the that's the
um
there's a sign up place for that
anyway so so
that's the only
everything else will be super nerdy i i
promise you
uh so so so what i'm again so what we're
going to do is
for the first sort of five minutes or so
i'm going to present i'm going to frame
the
the problem we're going to solve right
so there are a couple of slides where
i'll do just do the framing
and then we'll get on to actually doing
doing the work
so so this is again i'm going to by the
way this is directly copied and i used
to teach both the grad and the undergrad
ai course at georgia tech at one time
long long time ago so this is actually
copied from one of my slides at that
time so not not super
good but still i i so this is basically
i believe
that what i'm going to present to you is
a fairly
fairly detailed description
of how a model gets built
with special emphasis on the data
pipeline of that model right so so to
build a predictive model using machine
learning you start off you know you work
for a company
you work for you know you're at a
university blah blah you know you have
data right
so so the base data the problem of
course why why do we need feature
engineering well the base data in the
form that it exists in most companies
now in us in a crm or
whatever you know is is not typically
directly consumable by models right so
data has to be transformed
into the specialized artifacts that we
call features right
so so and the transformation of data to
features based data features is what is
feature engineering so those are you
know so kind of here are the steps right
so you pull in based data
and the first step that you go through
is something that we are calling ingest
and analyze so basic basically you are
checking
if this base data and and let's just
assume we are working with structured
tabular data this also applies to
other types of data of course it just
makes it simpler to lay some context so
let's say the context is structured you
know you're pulling in tables right
so so the goal of this step is to make
sure
that eventually you're left with stuff
that supports good modeling
so you're going to look at it you're
going to test for some properties
and and and and if if certain of those
properties are not satisfied you're
going to
treat the data clean the data right so
so and and what i think happens is that
you go through this cycle of sort of you
pull in a attribute you go through this
analyze assess and treat and clean you
know analyze you know you you make a
test hey
do i have too many missing values
right
or
do i have bias i do i have skews you
know there are a bunch of standard
checks and we'll go through
a lot of them
so you run the check you assess health
it's like hey this has a lot of missing
values right that assess health and then
you treat i mean the treatment could
be this column i i cannot redeem it it's
just ninety percent of the values are
missing so the treatment could be just
throw it away or it could be that hey i
impute it right yes
uh it's salvageable i impute it and and
and and or i impute the missing values
through logic that i set up you know i'm
going to use the mean median now
i i don't know what it is but i'm going
to impute it and then that's going to
result in a clean data set so you go
through this repeatedly
and then what leaves this step
is ideally
clean data
that is model worthy or
model creation worthy right
and then with that you actually entered
the process where you will create the
features
feature creation itself
we believe
is sort of doing three distinct things
right the first thing is you generate
candidate features what are features you
know roughly features are predictive
elements right
so you will generate candidate features
what does that mean well i mean imagine
that that
let's take a real case right let's take
a company metlife right one of the
largest insurance companies in the world
in fact they happen to have the largest
travel insurance business in the world
right
so you are a
modeler you are a data scientist at
metlife and the travel insurance dudes
the person that runs marketing for
travel insurance comes to you and says
that look
we need to acquire we need to sell
travel insurance i need to run marketing
programs who do i go after right
so can you build me can you
can you build me a model of propensity
to purchase travel insurance
so the data scientist at this step
the data scientist thinking hey what
even predicts
that propensity what makes somebody buy
travel insurance right and they might
say well you know
if you don't travel i mean you'd never
really have a need to buy travel
insurance so maybe
how much you travel or your propensity
to travel is a feature
then you know she might think well you
know
the travel insurance itself is good is
going to get tacked on as a cost right
so you have your ticket cost on top of
that so maybe
if you're economically disadvantaged
you'd be less likely to purchase travel
insurance than otherwise so maybe
affluence is a marker right and and you
would go through this step and it's okay
here are
27 things
i believe are predictive of purchasing
travel insurance typically of course we
almost always go through that you know
in mobile wallets so we are now running
110 120 models in production for each of
those we go through that almost
in every case you go through and it's a
super ad hoc but that's sort of the
first step right
so
at the end of that step so okay so fine
i i leave this step with sort of
a number of
features that i believe are going to be
predictive but i'm still living with
only labels right names of those
features
i think that affluence predicts
propensity to buy right
i still need to instantiate them i still
need to materialize those features from
the data i have right so so the next
step is okay so i had this data
that i cleaned and kind of
brought in and now i i think i have all
these predictors
so how do i create those predictors or
proxies for those predictors from the
data i have
and then two things might happen here
right
and and and let me give you an example
so so
in the in the travel insurance example
we saw that the two the two predictors
we thought of were propensity to travel
and
affluence right
and clearly the data i have especially
if you work for a company like metlife
is that you have
very very rich historical
insurance sales data i mean i've sold
tens of millions of cases of travel
insurance
i have each one of those records i you
know
the name the address the person who
bought it blah blah so i take that and i
i believe that hey
um
how can i from this how can i how do i
know if a person travels or not sort of
very difficult right i mean you might
have a person only one time in that
and and and you
you really don't know whether whether
whether you know they may have bought
travel insurance from a different
company they made it so you you you
might say that look from the data i have
i really cannot build a proxy for travel
propensity
uh for affluence you say okay for
affluence you know i have the the zip
code the the postal code for where they
live
and of course you know it is relatively
easy to get data you know just just just
publicly available data on
home prices at specific postal codes in
the us for instance in the zip code you
can get and you say that i'm going to
create a proxy where if it's a high home
price zip code i'm going to call this
person affluent or not so in that case
you might say from the data i can
actually create a proxy for that feature
bottom line they're going to be one of
two things
you can use the data to create that
feature or you cannot if if you cannot
then you might say that hey maybe i need
to get external data to throw in with my
data to create that feature bottom line
you generate candidate features
you instantiate those features you have
you create real features and then cajon
if you
animate
and then of course you go through sort
of a final treatment right you reduce
dimensionality you some some attributes
are categorical you encode them into
numerical in all the well-known steps
and then what leaves that step are sort
of model ready features
so now you have your model ready
features
these days often you put them into
something called a feature store
uh you don't have to you
most people have homegrown but you know
let's let's call you put them into a
feature store and then you start the the
sort of the model pipeline part because
you know if you animate through just
animate through the rest okay
so so basically you know and here
clearly i've abstracted away a lot of
lot of a lot of different steps because
we are mostly interested in the data
pipeline you know you you bring in
techniques you train with the features
you see hey what works what does not
uh then then if you're happy
you deploy the model
and and of course the model is providing
ops feedback right so that that sort of
what we believe and
animate through yeah so you can see that
we are showing you the the data pipeline
in blue the stages and the connectors
and so the model pipeline in red right
so this this creates by the way feel
free to ask stop me anytime and ask
questions right otherwise it's no fun
uh and and and and sort of this part the
blue part is what is known as feature
engineering
so that's that's the topic that's the
and typically you know
as i described it you saw that parts of
it were very ad hoc i mean
uh the the subset of you who build
models know that that you know the whole
whole pro this data pipeline is very
much sort of an ad hoc process right
so
so what tools what kind of tooling is
available right so how how far
does sort of technology help you
you know for the for the
initial ingest analyze and the final
treatment there are clearly a whole
bunch of you know it's it's mostly
running statistical tests
making decisions and doing something so
clearly there are a whole bunch of
tools available just think of the pandas
framework right i mean
where where those tests are available
for you but still it's it's
which test you choose to run
the judgment you make
and the treatment you choose to make in
the treatment there are even tools that
can automate the treatment but the
treatment you make is is is up to you
right so yes tools are available to to
to to you know you don't need to code
you know specific statistical you know
you don't need to quote principal
component analysis yourself i mean that
is available but you still need to make
the choices right
and then for candidate uh yeah for for
these two there's really no tooling
available and it's very very very ad hoc
extremely ad hoc
uh and and and by the way so there are
of course uh as as many of you know
uh in emelops somebody put up their hand
and said there are auto feature
generators of course there are
but
and again this is an intellectual choice
so i am deeply opposed to auto feature
generators in fact that's one of the
motivations for this yes i mean you can
get you know you can
get an automatic feature generator feed
it all the attributes and it's going to
generate
you know every possible permutation you
know
log of a variable square of a variable
you know multiply three variables
and and and it's going to tell you that
okay the the you know you have
attributes a1 through a n and it's going
to tell you the a1 times a 20 29
take the square root of that and take
the log and all of a sudden it's like
super correlated with your target
variable right so i am deeply opposed to
that you know again as as as all the
math guys will know
that
that
yes
you might find it interesting there and
it might prove to predict it there but
it doesn't mean anything a because it's
not explainable and what does that even
mean
right
and b because it's not explainable
what often happens is that the the
performance at that time doesn't follow
through in practice right it's it's it's
the stability of this auto created
features often ends up being very poor
as well so generally most modelers don't
end up using them a lot i mean they're
sort of yeah
fun tool to have
so the people typically people go
through sort of this whole candidate
feature generation and so on
and and there's you know it's it's it's
almost completely ad hoc
clearly many many uh many um
feature stores available as all of you
know you know techdon and huff's work
and and all
good stuff
and then of course the third party data
and features also not much availability
right so this is this is the context
so with that framing basically what i'm
going to take you through now
is what we believe is an interesting way
to proceduralize systematized feature
engineering and i'll bring it as well so
let's let's move into the main part
is it clear so far does it
okay
all right so cajun if you will okay so
what will not say we don't need to i
mean this is i mean
this is the structure of the library
i've kind of explained it already we can
we can
so so so you know so um
so we'll take you to future engineering
with the novos and ofos is of course and
now you know until now i was not looking
down now i will because we'll run
through a ton of stuff i have some notes
so uh onovos is a is an end-to-end live
you know feature engineering library
right and and the idea is that that it
it implements a systematic and
procedural data pipeline
um sort of with enterprise data at one
end and model ready features with the
other
you know i'd be lying to tell you it
automates everything it's not possible
but definitely systematic procedure and
you'll see it gives you uh certain
certain automations which should be
which would be super useful right so we
created anovos
for three reasons right and again i'm
summarizing everything
the first two to proceduralize feature
engineering you know majority of steps
in future engineering you know such as
those i showed you
are very ad hoc and trial and error
making them very vulnerable to mistakes
right
so we wanted to make feature engineering
much more systematic and much less error
prone
so the contribution here is not that we
are investing something radically new
but we are making a
sort of inherently ad hoc process
systematic and and procedural and
hopefully reducing errors and as we go
through the the demonstration and the
workbook
notebook
i will point that out to you in a bunch
of hey look this is something that
happened so easily it would it would it
would
otherwise that wouldn't be the case
second
we wanted to add a few new capabilities
and and in another you'll see we i'll
introduce you to the the new science if
you will new computer science if you
will
in particular there are two broad
buckets one is we will introduce
something called the notion of data
stability you know so we all know drift
but drift is a post-facto uh
measure
something happens you imagine i'll i'll
introduce you the notion of being able
to predict drift
and make actions take actions based on
on on that
and the second thing i'll
uh the second broad category there are a
few individual things there is in the
candidate feature generation to mapping
okay that's one of the hardest and the
most error-prone parts of feature
engineering and i'll introduce you to
something we have introduced called a
feature recommender and feature explorer
that that hopefully makes that part
a lot less
a lot less error-prone
and finally you know this is sort of
hard to demonstrate here
but one of our goals was to enable
scalable feature engineering right i
mean all of you i'm sure or those of you
who build models end up using things
like you know pandas libraries of course
they're great
but they're all mostly single threaded
and and perform in memory computation
right so so they don't scale very well
in the case of when your data sets are
meaningfully large
and and our data you know by the way
anova was created for our you know
our team has been building these little
components over the past three four
years we recently
thought to kind of
put it out
but but in our case because we work with
lots of data so the idea was to was to
enable scalable feature engineering so
uh you know right now unoffice runs on
spark right
and again that's also a first step i
mean spark itself is heavy in time one
of us will run on
lighter scaling frameworks you know
things like ray
and so on and so forth right so that
that will also happen but enabling
scalability was a key goal
so with that
uh so let me introduce you so what i'm
going to what what we're going to do is
do
the instead of just showing you stuff at
random we will actually run you through
feature engineering for a specific use
case
uh this is a use case that we are quite
familiar with because we work with a
bunch of companies in this space
so we'll we'll take you through uh
the use case of credit risk modeling
right
and the goal
is to predict
um
a loan applicant's capability to repay
the loan
so the data set that we will work on is
a kaggle data set so we are giving you
uh the different the different
um the place where you can find it and
so on and we enhance the data set a
little bit to
to demonstrate some of the capabilities
of unovers because the data at the end
just one snapshot one table
uh i'll point out where we enhanced uh
so so just to show you this is this is
the the structure of the data it's a
it's a
it's loan application data
each row represents a loan and there are
three kind of
three
buckets of attribute you know there is a
there's a loan id
then there is sort of a set of
descriptor variables
that give you
um
characteristics of the applica of the
loan and of the applicant
and then there's a target variable right
that tells you that hey did this loan
have difficulties paid payment
difficulties or not clearly this is an
example of a supervised learning
scenario we have chosen this but easy to
explain i mean on offers you can use in
unsupervised things as well
uh but but makes sense i mean that's
that's the that's the thing right so so
with that let's let's go to the uh and
before we go to the notebook and the
work and the and the flow of this is
going to be pretty simple
we are first
it's very much like what i showed you
earlier we'll first do
uh eda
we'll first do the ingest and analyze
phase and show you how anovas helps
there
and then after that we'll go into the
feature creation phase uh where we will
follow through those steps you know
we'll
generate candidate features we'll uh
we'll instantiate we'll create those
features
and then we'll do the different checks
and then then
with the
candidate feature set i'll go through
the final kind of you know
dimensionality reduction cardinality
treatment and so on and so forth produce
the model ready features so that will be
the structure of the demo right
so now i will have to pay attention to
my notes because we're going to go to
the notebook
so
so let's go to the notebook kajal
so the first step
is is uh and and now those of you who
have downloaded it will will hopefully
work with us through this i'll point out
where
you know if it's going to take a few
minutes i'll just say you don't run it
you can get the download it so in in
anovas eda
eda is performed um
did we
yeah couldn't
keep going
so we first we first load the data right
by the way so i'm not going to spend
time on how to install lenovo's uh you
know
there are tons of instructions you guys
are used to installing open source stuff
i'm not going to spend there so um
so the first step is loading the data
so so i think um
you can show the unoffice load utility
so this is this is the the the the
unoffice load utility we we we run it
and the data gets loaded in the data
gets loaded in clearly of course
uh canonical problem so many columns so
many attributes difficult
so so let's now get into eda to make
sense of this data and clean this data
right
so in anovas you can perform eda in two
ways
you can use the anova's report utility
or
you can call individual functions from
the analyzer module we'll go through
both
we'll first let's let's let's go through
one of what's reports
so onovos offers two types of reports
basic and full
and what kaijan is showing and here do
not run the report function it'll take
take some time
so we have a
pre-saved report there already so you
can pull it up
so so these are the commands to generate
the basic and full reports
and what we'll do is we'll we'll use a a
pre-saved we'll use a pre-saved full
report that we constructed on the loan
application data that you just loaded in
to demonstrate so this is the onovo's
report
so so it has six tabs
the first two tabs are really meta tabs
the the executed summary
and the wiki
um
that you know
the first step is just a summary the
second tab contains the the the
different data types and so on so much
of the information content is in the
last four tabs which we'll now go
through in in more detail so the first
tab
yeah that's the the wiki
now the the third tab or the first of
the four tabs is descriptive statistics
right
so here right at the beginning you see a
global summary of you know of of the
data number of records number of
attributes the first thing that that the
team at mobile wallet usually focuses on
when analyzing a new data set
is the fill rate or missing percentage
of each attribute
because it can you know it can help you
decide whether you need to throw it away
you need to impute the missing values
blah blah right
if there are too many missing values
that's not a good modelable uh
data
so uh so we can we are now looking at
you know
a bunch of sub tabs from from measure of
counts through measure of shape
so so if we order by missing percentage
here
we can see that 70.5
of entries
are missing in the attribute common area
median right and and i'm not going to go
through each one but you can see it so
so over 70 of attributes are missing
you know normally we say that if it's
six more than 60 or 65
it's kind of unsalvageable so we we
you know because even imputation results
might might not
you know
will end up misrepresenting the data
so so at mobile wallet for instance we
would choose to drop that column we will
take it away from further analysis right
another metric
that is worth looking at if you go to
measure of central tendency another met
you know
is more than mode percentage right
because
uh it shows you skews
it shows you bias towards specific
values
so you can see here that if we order by
mode percentage which kajalan has done
we can see that the attribute flag can't
mobile
has more than 99 percent this is the
kaggle data set right more than 99 of
the entries
as value one it's just just a one
again super unlikely to provide useful
information and we would typically
consider dropping this column as well
personally i like measures of
percentiles a lot as well and if you
open up measures of percentiles
and let me see i had a couple of notes
here you know because this is sort of
super super useful in looking out in in
in doing outlier judgment right so hey
are there extreme values or not right so
for example if you alphabetize
uh if you alphabetize by the attribute
you can see that that the attributes
like amount annuity amount credit so
these are all uh
attributes related to
amounts of money
are are and if you if you scroll to the
right kajan and you can see that there's
a huge difference between their 99
percentile and the max value right so
you can see that the 99 percentile is 69
300 the max value is like almost one
ninety thousand
uh the the one below is even even
starker
uh and and and and that that tells me
that i i will need to do outlier
treatment for these attributes right so
very you could very very quickly see
that
and at the you know and in here i'm just
showing you the the the
the
numerical values you know we also have
visualization because if you scroll down
you can also find histograms for
numerical and categorical attributes
this is of course a numerical attribute
um
uh let's let's uh let's show um a
categorical attribute as well yeah so
you can see that this is the the
distribution for instance for name
income type right
so until now so i'm showing you these
things basically i'm doing the the the
the
things i showed you in just an analyze
i'm looking at attributes i'm running
some tests i'm deciding
but we were doing it manually i mean
this is typically how most of you will
do it right here we were doing with
anovus you would do it with some other
report you would say that hey let me run
measures of percentile let me run this
so but here until now i'm showing
examples of manually drawing conclusions
over the quality of the data by checking
individual properties right percentile
measures
tendency and all again experienced data
scientists
might follow that path right
but for most modelers what will be
useful is an automated quality check
that presents data quality along the
most critical dimensions in a
consolidated manner right so we make
this available in the quality check tab
in our report
and and and
and and
basically the quality checker is not
only flagging quality issues but it also
helps make treatment decision
decisions very efficiently as we'll show
you so this is a key differentiated
feature in infos right
so in quality checker we have five
uh it it basically shows you quality
along five five dimensions so there are
null detection idness detection
biasedness detection invalid entries
detection outlier detection right again
there are other tests possible
but we have found that these five checks
suffice
for
a majority of modeling scenarios right
so clearly can't take you through all of
them i but i decided to show you
uh biasedness detection so because let's
go to biasedness detection and give an
example
so in the descriptive stats tab
excuse me guys
so if you remember in the descriptive
stats tab
i showed you how mode percentage under
measures of central tendency
can reveal skews right
vastness detection automatically does it
for you
by leveraging that information
automatically in the background
also if treatment is enabled which will
be
enabled to the config files right so and
and we'll show you the yaml file at the
end if the treatment is enabled which
you could have easily configured
it will it will treat as well in this
case for instance
um
the treatment could be automatically
remove
highly skewed column so it'll do that
automatically and you can see it's it's
showing you the skews automatically
right
so same as biasedness we won't show you
all the rest but idness detection is
leveraging cardinality measures
outlier detection is leveraging
percentiles and dispersion measures and
so on right
but basically there are a few examples
these are just just a few examples but
the qual what the quality checker does
is that it includes a comprehensive list
of sort of data
quality assessments
that more
modelers need to perform
at both the row and column levels right
so we should point out
it's not that you can't do it
elsewhere you can run each of this test
do it manually
but what we are showing you is basically
doing this all consolidated right you
didn't have to make any choices
basically it and you know you you can
make choices as to what treatment you
want to make
and you can
code that into your config file
but once you do that the assessment and
the treatment is done automatically for
you
so after quality checks
so we'll take you to another very
important part of eda
observing and understanding attribute
associations
super important right because you need
to see how the different attributes
you're pulling in are correlated to each
other
and we'll we will do that through the
attribute associations tab
in the in the report
so
anova lets you understand attribute
association through a bunch of different
techniques and if you do the drop down
we can show them through correlation
matrix through information value through
information gain and through variable
clustering right you can use all of this
to see attribute associations
so let's look at correlation matrix to
start
so the report is showing you this is the
correlation matrix so let's pick a value
let's pick
um
look at the coefficient written amount
credit which is the second row
and amount goods price which is the
third column right so you can see that
it's it's it's very high right more than
0.9 and of course you're not going to
use both as as as features or to
generate features so you drop one of
them because they're so correlated
moving on
so let's look at uh looking at
associations from information value
by analyzing information value by the
way in the credit scoring domain where
we are the example we are showing you
information value ends up being very
widely used right
so you can see
under iv calculation can you order
yeah you did
if you order by the column iv
we can see that the attributes related
to external source
um are all have high information value
right
so and of course this is being this is
being looked at by looking at how they
uh how predictive they are how how
related they are to the target variable
that's how this is done
uh and and and just by looking at this
particular thing you can make a very
important conclusion right just just by
looking at this can go up for a second
here
just by looking at this this would
indicate to you that hey this external
source attributes either directly
or through some convolution are likely
to create good features because they
have such such high information value
right now i'm going to show you later
how
other things might cause you to doubt
that but at least at this stage you
would you would think that
you know very similar analysis can be
done uh from information gain as well
and i'm not showing you kaijun was
scrolling down so
in all of this there is visualization
underneath as well so you know in the
interest of time sort of i'm not not
quite showing you that but all of them
have have the visualizations
the the final technique in this is
variable clustering
and um
and most of you know it's
computationally a bit more expensive
but it's a very powerful alternative to
the correlation matrix right where
correlation matrix shows you pairwise
correlation is going to show you
uh basically pairwise for every
attribute against every other attribute
this shows you group wise correlation
cluster wise correlation so it's super
powerful right
and and and you'll see at the end once i
go to the final kind of step at the end
variable clustering become very useful
as a dimensionality reduction technique
as well and we have some pretty
interesting interesting visualization as
well where
you can see all the all the clustered
attributes together and so on
again there are packages that offer you
these things they're a package where you
can run information value calculation
there are packages where you can run
information gain or correlation matrix
or even variable clustering
though you know do it is we haven't come
across one that do all of these together
so the the the power of sort of sort of
anova is the is the availability of all
this in a consolidated manner
finally we go to the last last tab of
the report which is a core contribution
in an ovals called drift and stability
right
so all of you know drift is so
all of you know what what what data
drift model what what drift means
and
most of you probably also know that
drift is one of the main causes of the
lack of resiliency of models right
so by the way just to just to frame
resiliency is that hey i build a model
the predicted
accuracy is very high
but i deploy it in two weeks the model
starts screwing up
so it the the the the performance in
production
doesn't follow the model degrades very
quickly right i mean that's and you know
these days
uh and we suffer from it a lot uh in in
our our clients as well so these days
there is almost
uh a tautological belief in the in at
least the mlaps community
that you know initially it was hey
predictive accuracy predictive accuracy
predictive accuracy now there is a sense
that i want models that are
that have good predictive accuracy but
are resilient so i would rather pick a
model
that is
fine with predictive accuracy and
resilient rather than a model which
showed incredible predictive accuracy at
at build time and a test time but
quickly degrades in production right so
resilience is sort of super important
and and one of the main reason
for why models misbehave is drift
and and
all of you probably know that
that when you detect
model misbehavior when your model in
production is not doing very well one of
the first things you check is drift
and almost every package whether you you
know
from data robot to sage maker to to
simple pandas packages they all offer
drift functions basically you call a
drift function with two arguments
you have
two data sets and the drift function
basically gives you the distance between
those two data sets
so in anovas
we provide you drift analysis
and we provide you drift analysis
between uh i had a couple of notes here
um
so by the way so i should also tell you
yeah so i have you so in order to detect
drift or to talk about this i need
historical data the kaggle data set
doesn't have that right it just has one
snapshot so this is a point where we
have enhanced so what we have gone what
we've gone back is generated you know i
think six or eight
periods worth of data in the back right
so we have simulated it and we've
generated it just to show uh this part
so here um
in a real environment of course the data
will naturally evolve over time so so
you will you will have that anyway
so the first component what what kajanan
is showing you is data drift analysis
and it compares the drift between two
data sets you can save which two data
sets of course
and and summer summarizes the attribute
wise drifting for each you know clearly
drift is one attribute to another
attribute-wise drifting
based on four very very well known
distance measures which i'm sure many of
you recognize psi and jst and so on
intuitively the larger the drift
the larger the value
the larger the drift right between those
two attributes uh and this is typically
you know in in a in a real world setting
this will typically be data that i just
fed into my model now
versus data that i trained the model on
uh currently if you go down i mean you
can see that the the the data attributes
flagged by unovos includes sort of three
attributes related to external sources
right
which implies that the distributions of
these attributes have changed and here i
wanted to bring up something else
previously in attribute association when
i was looking at information value if
you remember the external source
attributes ended up having the highest
information value so just based on
analysis or our observations at that
point we would have thought that hey
these are great things to build features
on right because they have such high
information value here and this is this
is basically one of the one of the
things of feature engineering but here
you're seeing
that these guys drift
which means that even though they have
high infra so high information value is
a predictor of high predictive accuracy
this high drift is a predictor of they
will probably end up creating features
that will make the model less resilient
it's a very it's a dichotomy that we
that modelers will if if you had this
kind of stuff you would already know and
now you can make an informed decision
right you can say that hey
do i want to use it if the information
value is so high
that i'm
the predictive accuracy is so high i may
use it anyway
but if if it's kind of middling that i
probably will not use it simply because
it will produce non-resilient models
right
and we can we can also visualize the
drift stats and drift indicators in the
data health section
where you can see that you know in total
six attributes are being identified and
drifted at the point when this this
report is generated
the second component which is really
completely new
is of of
this part is data stability analysis
so let me give you a sense of what
stability is right so you'll see that we
are computing stability values of each
attribute
so again those of you i'm going to give
you a math analogy so drift is a point
metric at a point in time t
two two two
two data items have a certain drift so
drift is a point attribute
you can think of stability as the first
derivative of drift
right so d drift to dt it's basically
the drift characteristics of an
attribute over time you can also think
of stability as a predictor of drift
as i'm seeing how things that
are drifting over time over multiple
time periods
uh i'm able to assess
you know
yes i mean in the drift property you
might have seen external source drift
in one time period but that just may be
an anomaly right it may not be drifting
overall so stability shows you drift
over time
and this is super powerful and i'll give
you some examples of how it has helped
us and software clients so again i'm not
going to give you the math of stability
here but if you want
the it's very interesting so stability
is basically it's trying to understand
the baseline distribution and seeing
what varies happy to share the math with
you as well by the way i have a uh
many of you probably are aware of
towards data science so i had an article
a few months ago on on stability in
towards data science which
which also talks in more detail
so you can stability
is a value between zero and four that we
compute or that anovas computes
the lower the value the lower the
stability typically two or less is
considered unstable and three or four is
stable
and three is
semi-stable as well so based on this you
can see
that i had some notes
um you can see
uh
that that the
attribute common area median kajanan
which is yeah common area median
where the stability index is smaller you
know is is is two
uh is is not a stable data item and is
likely to drift with time right and you
can do it for for all of the attributes
we can also visualize the stability
index details for each attribute below
you know you can see how stable they are
so
attribute stability
turns out to be one of the most powerful
ways to create
stable models resilient models right so
basically the way that we use it
is
when a modeler is going to model or
update the model at all given times we
have the stability values being computed
and the idea is that hey i want to
create features
that that are stable as well okay which
means i want to yet use stable
attributes to create features
that's my first choice but as i told you
earlier if i find an attribute that is
not sort of clearly
creating features with attributes
stability of zero and one is is is is
not advisable but there are borderline
cases where you know you have stability
of two or two point three or something
and and and
you say that this is so predictive the
information value of this or information
gain is so high
that even though this attribute is
somewhat stability challenged i'm still
going to use it right
and by using it i'm going to create the
model that has high predictive accuracy
but i expect
it will not be resilient so what i can
do
is i can skew
my ml ops my monitoring resources
towards the models that you expect to
drift
and and and monitor them
more carefully than models that you that
you uh
expect not to drift that much or
not to not to misbehave that much right
so i'll give you an example so we run
120 models in production and our uh mean
time to update was like
totally crappy right i mean
and you know we run you know for
instance we
we create models of gender and age and
blah blah and so on i think our mean
time to you know we we we wanted to have
mean time to update so we do model
checking like once a quarter we wanted
mean time to update to be
like 90 days
so it it ended up being like 17 days or
something i mean some models were good
some of us were really bad like four
days after putting on they were
i mean they were not doing well
so using stability so we've increased
our mean time again you know i'd love to
tell you we've taken into 90 days we
haven't uh we have still worked but we
have taken it from 17 days to 45 days
right so so
just just by using stupid these are some
of these are the
underlying you know we can skip
we can discuss it outside with you guys
i just want to finish
uh the other stuff as well so so that's
that's um
so now now now let's head back to the
notebook hopefully you get you see how
the the report gives you canned stuff
that is useful clearly all of this
is doable yes
[Music]
ask that question one more time please
you know that that clap caused me to
lose 10 seconds of your question just
ask a question one more time
that's right that's right
correctly i need to use both of these
data sets to get uh addresses a drift
metric for my features
so isn't using the evaluation data set
already at the future engineering
stage
got it got it
great great question so let me let me i
i think i was not super clear so
yes so you are right
normally the way and i'm gonna just
go out this for a few seconds just to
spare my eyes uh i'm sorry did you lose
me
sorry guys i i just need to give my eyes
a two second rest as i uh
so so basically what what yes you're
right so normally drift is used
when a model has has kind of misbehaved
to see the evaluation data set and the
current production data set what i was
saying here is that
so we don't recommend that that is used
in in in
in
in the way that i'm showing you what
what i'm showing you is that imagine
that your data set is evolving in this
case what's happening is that
imagine at the end of each month
so you know so we work with some of the
largest buy now pay later companies who
are doing risk prediction right so
they're giving
hundreds of thousands of loans they're
evaluating hundreds of thousands of
loans a month so at the end of each
month you can imagine there is a new
instantiation of the data set
right so so from month one to let's say
month
they're end data sets right
so what i was telling you is that what
anovas does
is that for the drift part
anovas can reveal the real drift
from let's say the way we use it we look
at the drift from i think
kajalan can tell you what we have a
canonical like six months ago to now
right the last data set to six months
ago i mean that's a very quick and dirty
thing of hey has it drifted we don't
look at the and evaluation but the
stability is a it's continuously
computed right so stability is telling
you depending upon which
sort of ground zero data set you have
identified as the basis right it could
be data set one it is six whatever in
our case i think we even change the
ground level every six months or so it
is telling you
when i look at every data set from
ground zero to now
what's the what's the the the the time
time
time variant drift basically that's what
we're we're not yeah but we're not
telling you that that the model and the
evaluation should be used this is just a
way for you to see how your data is
evolving
all right
so um
excuse me
so of course you can you can do all of
this individually in the data analyzer
module as well
um
just you know i and and and um
let me see
so
we can we can we can go into each one of
those things right i mean everything
that we showed you can do
it does automatic checking as well
so what we will do is we will go we'll
show you one thing we'll show you an
example of doing outlier detection right
which is of course super very very
common thing in in modeling
so again manually detecting outliers is
very hard which is what people end up
doing anyway right you pull up the data
set
it is possible with small data sets
but but practically
um practically impossible to do with
data sets of a meaningful size even this
kaggle data set right
so so what what we will do is we'll use
the quality checker module for auto
detection and i'll show you how that
happens uh here uh you know basically
what kajanan is doing is is um calling
the the the quality checker module right
and what he's doing is is one of the
things that we offer in anovas is that
you don't need to call it with i mean
you can call it on all the attributes
but you can see there is a there is a a
uh
artifact called list of columns right so
basically what kaijanan is doing to to
to make this somewhat limited
is is in the list of column he's putting
all the columns
that have to do with days basically that
contains the term days so he's
restricting it
so
after that uh you know you run that we
are getting basically this output
and and and let's let's let's first look
at this distribution using measures of
percentile right so we are looking at
basically uh
uh um
the days related attributes from a
percentile perspective and we can see
there are mostly negative values
which is which is right right because
all of these values are effectively
how many days before the application
date so they should they they should be
negative
uh in fact all value should be negative
right
that means that that if you look at
days employed
if you look at the the road is employed
you can see some positive values
and then they are they are invalid
day's birth is the applicant's age the
first the first row if you look at the
minimum value which is basically the
maximum age in days
it's like greater than 150 years right
so clearly
that is incorrect and this is in the in
the real kaggle data we're showing you
the day's last phone change is when the
users lost change their phones right and
the minimum value is like 10 000 days
which is like 30 years so that that
doesn't sound right as well right
and oh but all of these i'm looking at
the output and making manual
observations i can because those are but
you know but but but it is very easy to
make mistakes right because because
there are so many of them
so instead what we will do is we'll use
the quality checker outlier function
uh where
effectively what we have done
is we have developed an ensemble
technique right which takes
i have some notes which takes multiple
statistical methods into account for the
detection purpose you know including
percentile standard deviation
interquartile range so it it creates
all of these right
so so again this is sort of a
simple example of a differentiator in
anova so we we don't know of sort of
efficient and and automated
proceduralization elsewhere so so let's
run it so as we saw through the the
measures of percentile results outlier
seems to exist on both end of the
spectrum so we are calling the function
now so we will use both as argument to
detection side because there are uh
outliers in both both both directions
and also we opted them to treat you know
to show you very simply we opted to
treat them right away all the outliers
by replacing those values with null
right
so let's look at the so once we run that
let's look at the measures of percentile
again to see
if they have been treated properly or
not and we can see that mostly they have
but unfortunately we can still see a
suspicious positive value in days
employed right
and and clearly this is because it
probably value appeared for quite a few
applicants this error happened for quite
a few applicants
so the default detection configuration
doesn't recognize it as an outlier right
so what we do
and our default detection configuration
says remember this is an ensemble
technique
and basically what the what our default
configuration is is saying that of all
my techniques
at least two have to flag something as
an outlier for me to get it as an
outlier right and and two didn't right
so in this case what we can do basically
what what we would do in this case is
change the min validation count from two
to one okay
uh which means that that even if one
technique flags it as an outlier it's an
outlier and
if i apply the function again you can
see
with that change that no more positive
values appear at all which means my
function is treated right
so by the way i just showed you outlier
detection there are a bunch of other
automated detections possible in the
quality checkers such as invalid entry
detection
uh you know that uses regular
expressions right so you can you can
identify regular expression and and
every entry can be validated against the
regular expression uh specification
uh to
do do invalid data entries right so
we'll we'll we'll we'll sort of sort of
skip this now but again happy to show
you to outside with bottom line a bunch
of these automated quality checks are
available for all of those five right
so hopefully so that that kind of ends
the eda part of unovos again it's a
little scattered because there is so
much but i tried to show you
two things one is
the two broad ways in which you can
ingest and analyze or analyze using
reports
or using
functions or using actually making
library calls
and the second thing i try to show you
is regardless of which one you use there
is a bunch of proceduralization
automation available that consolidates
output and shows you that should shave
that at least saves us a lot of time
so hopefully hopefully this this until
now this kind of sort of made sense now
i'm going to go on to
the next step which is how to generate
basically until now so we have treated
all the columns we have seen what they
have we have looked at you know and
basically we look at five things mostly
right invalid entry detection missing
missing value detection outlier
detection and and then i'm now
left with a modified data set
that
is model
modelable is model friendly so now i'm
going to go into the second step
which is oh yes
yes you want to take that
yeah so the currently um
so now let's go on to
uh so now i'm going to generate actually
generate features for this problem right
so um
basically here we'll select the features
that will power the the risk model
as i explained to you before
the first step in feature selection is
to generate a set of candidate features
i'm going to take a few minutes here so
this is a key innovation that we've
introduced and i showed you
uh early on using the example of um
of uh the travel insurance
uh how how how
sort of
ad hoc it is right you basically its
domain expertise you sit you think and
you generate your features
and a lot of errors happen here right
and errors here are very
critical because they kind of ripple and
magnify through your entire model if you
select a bad feature that's bad if you
do not select a good feature that's bad
as well
so so so it's it's you can think of this
as the cold start problem of feature
engineering right i mean you're starting
you don't know what should you start
with
so what we did was
um
so i'll show you
these
a bunch of different modules but but but
together you can think of that
as
trying to address the candidate feature
generation and the mapping problem so
basically this is what we've done right
so we have created a
a component called a feature recommender
feature explorer feature i forget what
we call
a
feature recommender and explorer and
feature mapper
that that gives you certain certain
abilities right so let's talk about the
feature explorer first
so basically the idea is that instead of
coming up yourself of course you can
come in with preconceived notions right
hey i know this will be predictive so
we'll allow that of course
but basically we we offer you an ability
to come and say this is what i am
this is the outcome i'm looking to
predict
in this domain
and this module returns to you
automatically
a set of feature labels that are proven
to be predictive of that right so how do
we do that
uh
and and we'll we'll show you we'll show
so so for instance here kajal if you'll
show them the call
yeah so it's called the feature
recommender
you give it you you provided two
arguments one is the outcome you're
seeking to predict
and the second argument is the domain
the industry domain where you are
looking to predict it
so here you know we are
looking to predict here we are looking
to predict credit risk in the finance
domain you could have said credit
coordinates in the lending domain it can
be sort of super super super add-on you
could say
likelihood of we are looking to predict
likelihood of loan default in bnpl you
know but bottom line you give it two
things
and it outputs for you
and you can see down it is outputting
for you features that you should
consider so what we have done is this
right
so over
last i don't know
six seven years or last five years that
we have been doing this and we have been
really interested in this
we have been scouring
establish you know
literature both academic both research
scientific literature as well as trade
literature
of
articles of documents
that talk about models and of course
we ourselves build models we have 50 60
customers in different dimensions also
many those
are brought in as well but the real crux
is that
imagine that that we have gone through i
think now close to seven million
documents and it's continuously ongoing
right
seven million documents that talk about
models
each document talks about a specific
model
and clearly we have developed now
the underlying text analysis expertise
to go and usually you know say hey
it's a it's a it's a chronicle of
somebody saying that
our team's saying that we wanted to
build this this is how we built it this
is the feature that
proved predictive
so we we continue to extract the
features and the outcomes from that and
we have put it together in a massive
corpus
so imagine that we have this corpus with
thousands of outcomes right and and of
course using sort of semantic ai we are
trying to group them
you know the creators thing could be
called you know could be
specified in 15 different ways right or
20 different ways so we have we have
grouped them
so we have thousands of outcomes and
hundreds of thousands of features right
so and it's pretty
happy to you know we should come and
it's pretty pretty clearly i mean it
will
evolve further right 10 years from now
it will be it will be and
but now
it's pretty interesting you can come in
and you can say hey i want to pre you
know you can't say you know you you can
trick it you can say i want to predict
color of
shirt and you know
somebody on the street in paris or
something it won't show you anything but
but
in
in in but it's it's pretty pretty uh
versatile and and it's it's always
always evolving
and we are making it we have made it
available as a generic corpus i mean you
can contribute as well right so so the
network effects can be very powerful we
have some of our clients you know who
use the
public corpus they create their own
private corpuses as well we allow that
as well but it's pretty pretty powerful
right
so that's that's and you can see here we
we made that call
and and and and these are the the
features it's it's suggesting
that's a sort of a first principles
contribution in anovas this this uh this
particular model
so this particular module we think is
sort of super cool and super interesting
but it's utility is still limited right
because it's giving you labels
labels are good but you still need to
instantiate to materialize those
features from the data you have right
which all which is also hard
so we have created a module called a
feature mapper another module called a
feature mapper now that you you have
these
uh these feature labels
so we have an attribute we have a thing
called a feature mapper i think um
because what is it called it's
yeah i think it still shows up and
recommended here but it will change the
function
name will change the feature
mapper
so you can where is the call to that
okay so now
so this actually maps your existing data
set basically tells you how you create
those features
from from from your native data right
and in this let me let me look at i i
want to
read my notes here just to
so
it has three arguments so this model has
three arguments
an attribute description
a domain and an outcome right the domain
and outcome is is as before what i gave
us before but the thing is what you're
feeding into it is your the data
dictionary of the data set you brought
in right so you can see the attribute
description file
uh is is is is basically nothing but a
representation of the data dictionary
and we can see that it contains two rows
two columns right a column column called
you know column for the attribute name
and a column for description where you
where you describe
it and and and now we are showing you
the output of the mapper module so you
can see there are four
the output is a table with four columns
the first two columns is simply the
attribute description file the name and
description of the of the attribute
the third and fourth columns
are the associated features that we
recommend with the attribute right so a
feature
and a feature description so each row
you can think of each
row as an association between an
attribute and a feature so a feature f
attribute a
and feature f
occurs in the same row you can think of
it as a relationship a composes f
right
so so so
we visualize this using a sankey diagram
below
so so we also allow you know an asanke
diagram is nothing but a bipartite graph
right so you can see i have i have a set
of attributes i have a set of features
and if there's an arc from an attribute
if there's a link from an attribute to a
feature
that's the thing that that that
attribute composes that feature right
a couple of interesting things there
could be one arc one link basically
saying that
that feature is just composed you know
we we call those atomic features those
are features that are composed of those
one attribute it could just be the
attribute itself or some you know square
log you know some something in that
attribute
if a feature has more than one link
that's a compound feature meaning you
those two attributes have to be
convoluted to to to to compose that
feature
and if a feature is no link that
basically says that i don't have data to
create that feature so i should look
outside right so this this this again
for us becomes sort of super super super
useful
does that make sense
again
it's hard to sort of see happy to talk
about it but we think you know this this
is is you know uh so so i had one of my
uh
one of the best phds under me was was
the underlying thing that sort of the
semantic ai
and the and the text analysis that
powers this
so
so now
so so this is sort of the the
recommended features
uh but there may be cases when the
modeler possesses domain knowledge
already right the modeler says that hey
i want to use i these are good but i
know there's other features that i think
are going to be good
uh and and and the modeler you know
she'd like to create custom features
herself so we allow that
uh in a in a with a model called the
expression parser which kaijanan is
showing you on screen now it's nothing
but a basically a 4gl interpreter right
basically it's it's it's it's where you
can code the feature in we give you a
sequel like uh uh see you know
uh sequel like interface where you use
sql like expressions to code that
feature you know i think the example
that kajal is showing you kind of this
is this new feature called income per
person that is calculated by you know
income divided by count of family
members or something right so so it's
basically a free form 4gl interpreter
where you can code custom features and
finally
there's another function called feature
transformation
that can be used to do basic math
operations in a square log exponential
you you you name it
and you know and for instance for
example we can apply
um
it's very easy to see for instance that
hey this attribute
so you might find that an attribute is
predictive of the target but then a
little a little further analysis tells
you that the relationship between that
and this the target is not linear right
super easy to see so you can say let me
try let me let me let me square it and
see if the the you know so
if the relationship
increases
also log transformations are super
useful right there are lots of long tail
attributes right especially if you have
skews
so you have a lot of long tail
attributes where you know and and logs
as you know are very very good
techniques to reduce long tail so we
give you this this whole feature
transformer module where you can do
you can take your attributes uh you know
and and and do different transformations
so basically we are giving you three
ways to generate candidate features one
is the feature recommender which is it
just tells you that hey you you should
think of these we give you a way to
generate custom features yourself
through a 4gl
and we give you a bunch of
transformations
that that based on the relationship you
see in the data you can apply this
transformation quickly to see if if the
transformed attributes themselves form
features right
so now we come to
so we now are full full if you show the
the
so now we have our full candidate
feature set and here i'll
we have a recommendation here
so this is our full candidate feature
set now it it composes of three typical
candidate feature sets are composed of
three items
one is the feature set suggested by the
feature explorer
number two the custom features that may
have been generated by the modeler
uh including you know you may have done
some transformations math transformation
and finally we also recommend
that you also put in your base
characteristic attributes as features as
well
right because they
just those the simple attributes
themselves could be features right
so the union of these three forms my
candidate feature set so now i enter
the last step
of of uh
feature engineering which is i now have
my candidate feature set i'm gonna prune
this feature set using a set of checks
right
to produce my final model ready features
so i will do five checks okay we
typically recommend five check a
stability check
cardinality check missing value check
you know
encoding uh categorical attributes and
dimensionality reduction so five checks
we'll perform those five checks here
first is stability check are my are my
features stable because i would rather
use stable features i gave you the
notion of attribute stability now we are
talking feature stability okay
so
we do this using the feature stability
estimation capability of anovas
uh which which which shows you the
stability of features
uh by the way the unlike data attribute
stability which was single valued right
so an attribute had a stability value
between zero and four
feature stabilities again we can discuss
the math outside
are output as a range min and max okay
the lower and upper bounds of this range
though are strongly indicative of how
stable we expect a specific feature to
be
for instance days employed minus day's
birth which was one of we ended up being
one of my candidate features through
those steps
is is the most unstable feature right
and and and and for instance we
we don't use it in practice
so that's so you check for stability and
you make an informed choice as to hey
ideally i want to only use stable
features but of course you might find a
feature is somewhat unstable but it's
high productivity based on what you've
seen before so you can make a different
choice
then we get to uh the the next the next
uh
check cardinality right
uh so
i'm sure all of you know that current
learning techniques most of the the
algorithm that you'll use to build the
model with don't handle high cardinality
as well
so so
we can apply the outlier categories
function typically here
to limit the classes for so we already
showed you examples of numerical
cardinality reduction in the eds section
uh the trick trickier is uh is is
categorical cardinalities so we we
we we offer outlier categories function
to reduce
uh cardinality for for basically a
number of classes for categorical
features
so and and that and the logic is super
simple so what this function does so
imagine you have a
categorical attribute with a bunch of
different
classes bunch of different categories so
it starts keeping each category so you
it order it based on frequency and then
start from the highest frequency
category it keeps keeping each category
until you have covered 95 of all
possible values until you've covered 95
percent of the universe and the rest
there could be many many many categories
in the rest if it's long tail you just
club as others
right so that's that's
however
uh and here is one of our kind of you
know we have seen uh again we've been
doing this for a long long time that
more than 15 so 15 is some of the magic
max number right more than 15 becomes y
15 very empirical i mean you can change
it to 18 if you like but we find that 15
is is sort of a good max number so
basically what outlier categories does
is that it keeps taking each category
until either it reaches 14
or it has covered 95 right so if it
reaches 14 it's not covered 95 it will
stop and club rest of it into others as
well okay
and you can see the example we are
showing you is the organization type
contains 57 unique values before the
treatment and then 15
after the tree
third check missing values right both
columns and rows uh in in in in the
feature so we remember we did missing
values in the base attributes now we are
doing it for the features
uh so we'll we'll basically treat the
columns and rows with too many missing
values uh you know and either remove
them or apply imputation
so so we can
call the so we call function null
columns detection i think i know showing
it to remove columns with greater than
60 missing values we use 60 you could
use something else
for row-wise null values
after checking you know we check with
null rows detection we can see that all
rows are fill rate less than 50 so
nothing needs to be
removed right so we can proceed to the
next step
so now what's left we need to impute
right so we still are missing values in
the ones that columns that qualify to be
kept
and imputation of course is is a very
hard problem
uh good imputation but imputation can be
done manually or a number of techniques
provided in innovos one of the coolest
features simple features in honor vos is
that we support auto imputation
right so we offer you a way to auto
impute
using five different methodologies and
these methodologies are mean median
k-nearest neighbors iterative computer
and matrix factorization right and and
basically it applies and it picks the
best one and the way it picks the best
one the criteria is it just sees and the
the the the
the best rmse value is picked as as sort
of the the best representer right so so
so we have uh
and of course you can use each of these
independently calling their function as
well but our iterative computer auto
computer you know ends up ends up
working great for us
fourth
categorical attributes encoding as as
you all know
uh learning techniques don't handle
categorical attributes very well so i
need to convert them to numerical
uh and and we provide a uh uh encoder
uh so we we have three three we provide
three encoding techniques
the most the li the one that we like the
most and we end up using the most
is based on a technical weight of
evidence w-o-e so we use that we offer
that
uh and and and and basically now we are
controlling the dimensionality of the
data set basically what what this does
is that for each attribute
uh it it computes the positive event
rate right and that event rate is used
as the encoded numerical value of course
when you do that the the values could be
all over the place so we we then apply
normalization to basically we we take
the max and min value set them to one
and zero and then fill in the rest
two other methods are also supported
label encoding and one hot encoding if
you like those so there are three values
and then finally we come to the last
step dimensional deduction right clearly
high dimensions
not not not not good in modeling
and and dimensional reduction can be
done using many ways one of our
favorites is variable clustering
so here you can see we are applying
variable clustering to reduce dimensions
and you you know
so if you look at the documentation for
this data center in kaggle you'll see
there are more than 40 columns
measuring normalized information about
the building where clients live in right
and for each one of those metrics three
kinds of measurements are taken in a
mean mode and median so they could be
highly correlated to each other you can
see that when i run variable
clusterization so we when we use the the
the variable clustering function
uh you can see it groups uh because for
instance you you can see that the
cluster zero uh
cluster has has so many different
attributes right
so we can only select one feature from
the cluster very very powerful technique
after this typically we end up you know
we don't stop here we end up you know
for instance we use a lot of information
value calculation to further reduce
right
so we can further reduce dimension id by
removing features with low information
value so i i may have basically what we
do is that we pick the attribute with
the highest information value from
variable clustering
uh you know you can see that that that
that binary features the with names
starting with flag have have have uh
almost zero information value so we
dropped them
and then finally you know we are also a
big fan of sort of latent features right
uh so in anovas we support
latent features including
either principal component analysis
or
autoencoder that is implemented in
tensorflow uh and you can see that when
you apply it
uh you know
we'll apply it on on features related to
amounts of money and according to the
result
four latent features are created which
can be treated as a summary for the 12
original features right
so so so that brings us you know so
we've gone through five things and now
we are showing you basically the path we
took
right so those and and it's almost and
you know and and when data scientists
and mobile wallet when they're building
models typically are recommended to
follow this path which is which is kind
of you know ends up end up works out
pretty pretty well for us
so that that kind of
brings us to the close happy today
questions will be will be outside
oh i i'm being reminded again
so hopefully a lot of you will use it
and apparently we have some very good
giveaways for those of you who give
stars i hate saying this but i'm i have
to say this
uh
so so um
and there are hundreds of those
apparently uh so so yeah so hopefully
this was helpful happy to take questions
we'll be there for today tomorrow
outside happy to sit with you
happy to take suggestions we want
contributors
clearly this is this is open source so
hopefully this was interesting
[Applause]
you